menschenleere millionenstädte im kampf
gegen das corona virus stehen mindestens
zwölf chinesische metropolen komplett
unter quarantäne kampfansage in richtung
rom italiens rechtspopulist salvini
hofft darauf bei den regionalwahlen
wieder an bedeutung zu gewinnen und ende
einer durststrecke johannes ludwig holt
für die deutschen rodler den ersten
weltcupsieg dieses winters
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend an diesem
sonntag das ist ihr nachrichtenüberblick
sport haben natürlich auch nachher mit
kristin otto hallo und genannt wir
wissen noch sehr wenig über das neue
corona virus dass china und die welt
zunehmend in atem hält der leiter der
nationalen gesundheitskommission in
china ließ heute aufhorchen mit der
information dass das virus ansteckend
sei als bisher gedacht und sich dabei
auch vom sars virus unterscheide er
sagte auch die forschungsergebnisse wie
das virus mutiert sei noch sehr begrenzt
china versucht mit drastischen maßnahmen
die ausbreitung in den griff zu bekommen
offiziell hat das land 56 tote bestätigt
angesteckt haben sich laut den behörden
2051 menschen und mehr als 40 millionen
menschen hat die regierung weitgehend
von der außenwelt abschotten lassen
straßen sind gesperrt flug und
zugverkehr wurden gestoppt und roller
überrannt von den immer weiter
steigenden zahlen von erkrankten
arbeitet das medizinische personal tag
und nacht aus ganz china werden ärzte
nach johann geschickt wo das virus
zuerst ausgebrochen ist
die abgesperrte stadt fast wie
ausgestorben
der bürgermeister von juan mit einer
eindringlichen warnung wegen des
frühlingsfests und der epidemie haben
circa fünf millionen menschen die stadt
schon verlassen
noch neun millionen sind da es ist die
aufgabe der partei und der regierung ihr
überleben zu garantieren handyvideos
tauchen in den chinesischen sozialen
medien auf die lange warteschlangen in
den krankenhäusern zeigen solche videos
werden von der chinesischen zensur
sofort gelöscht
nach außen bemüht sich die regierung um
offenheit
wir sind uns noch nicht klar bei
mögliche veränderungen der krankheit das
fortschreiten der epidemie wurde nicht
vollständig erfasst die stadt peking
sowie das ganze land befinden sich in
einem seltsamen ausnahmezustand die
straßen sind immer noch leer
die täglichen pressekonferenzen und die
radikalen eingriffe der chinesischen
regierung beruhigen und verunsichern
zugleich denn die sorge dass die
situation schlimmer ist als bisher
bekannt die bleibt das sagen auch diese
handy bilder vom westbahnhof in peking
eine große menge versucht die hauptstadt
zu verlassen es gibt gerüchte dass
peking dichtgemacht wird
die neue krankheit und die maßnahmen
dagegen was deutschland unternimmt damit
dass corona virus sich nicht ausbreitet
das können sie auch heute de nachlesen
etwa mit welchem test verdachtsfälle
geprüft werden
gut drei wochen ist es her dass die usa
im irak den iranischen general zu le
manie getötet haben seitdem hat sich die
lage in der region offenbar wieder
entspannt auch aus sicht der bundeswehr
seit heute bildet sie im nordirak wieder
sicherheitskräfte aus nach dem
luftschlag hatten die deutschen ihre
mission in erbil sicherheitshalber
unterbrochen und 90 bundeswehr soldaten
sind dort stationiert sie schulen
kurdische einheiten im kampf gegen den
sogenannten es vor genau einer woche
hatten in berlin zwölf länder ein
waffenembargo für libyen beschlossen
jetzt haben bereits mehrere teilnehmer
dagegen verstoßen das berichten die
vereinten nationen
in den vergangenen tagen wurden
demzufolge waffen gepanzerte fahrzeuge
und kämpfer in den krisenstaat gebracht
mit dem embargo sollte eigentlich ein
ende des krieges in libyen möglich
werden
in italien läuft gerade ein wichtiger
stimmungstest für die regierung die
selbst nicht in bester stimmung ist
sondern tief zerstritten
bei zwei regionalwahlen in kalabrien und
der emiglia romana geht es um die frage
wie stark wird die rechtspopulistische
lega gewinnt sie könnte es ganz eng
werden für die koalition in rom annette
hilsenbeck
am mittag haben schon mehr menschen als
bei der letzten regionalwahl ihre stimme
abgegeben in der emilia romagna in der
traditionellen linken hochburg zeichnet
sich ein kopf an kopf rennen ab zwischen
der sozialdemokratischen
regierungspartei pdl der
rechtspopulistischen lega deren chef
matteo salvini verteilt umarmungen
selfish küsse am letzten wahlkampftag
auf dem markt von bologna und den vier
weiteren orten er ist siegessicher und
macht klar was er dann fordern will die
in der regierung in rom müssen dann
entscheiden ob sie auf ihrem stuhl
bleiben der attackiert wird ich mache
das was ich tun kann mein lehrer und
unsere verbündeten bieten einen wechsel
an
soldini zurzeit wochen zeigt sich jedem
ort verbunden wenn er in dieser linken
region gewinnt sagen experten folgen für
die regierung in rom voraus wir werden
dann eine geschwächte italienische
regierung haben die opposition um
salvini wäre gestärkt und die gefahr ist
groß dass es dann eine krise in der
regierung gibt und sie in den nächsten
monaten auseinander bricht eine
gegenbewegung die sich sardinen nennt
will den sieg der lega verhindern
zehntausende zeigten zuletzt dass sie
nicht den rechtspopulisten zu stimmen
und hoffen damit andere zu mobilisieren
es gibt zwei lager auch auf dem markt
von bologna jene die für die
rechtspopulisten sind und die die gegen
sie stehen die regionalwahlen werden
zeigen wer mehr wähler hinter sich
vereint nach dem schweren erdbeben in
der osttürkei sinkt die hoffnung noch
überlebende zu finden mittlerweile
wurden 38 leichen aus den trümmern
geborgen mehr als 1600 menschen wurden
verletzt
bei eisigen temperaturen suchen die
rettungskräfte nach verschütteten
aus angst vor weiteren nachbeben trauen
sich viele nicht in ihre häuser zurück
mehr als 15.000 menschen wurden laut
behörden den schulen und sporthallen
untergebracht
bei einer demonstration gegen das verbot
der linksextremistischen
online-plattform links unten in die
media hat das gestern abend in leipzig
ausschreitungen gegeben
im stadtteil connewitz warfen vermummte
aus links orientierten gruppen böller
und steine
laut polizei wurden 13 beamte leicht
verletzt
zuvor hatten rund 1600 menschen
friedlich protestiert über das verbot
der webseite verhandelt am mittwoch das
bundesverwaltungsgericht und damit sind
wir an diesem sonntag beim sport und ich
habe nicht nur wintersport spanien
verteidigt den titel als handball
europameister in einem spannenden finale
in stockholm besiegte das älteste team
des turniers kroatien mit 22 20 dramatik
leidenschaft und am ende spanische jubel
tränen
zum zweiten mal feiert spanien sich als
handball europameister mit 22 20 gegen
kroatien in einem spiel wo mehrmals die
führung wechselt ein finale mit klasse
und gegenseitigen schwächephasen und wo
der spanische torwart bereits der
wagners zum matchwinner wird
sie haben exzellent verteidigt da war es
für uns schwer durchzukommen titel
verteidigt der beste spieler des
turniers ist aber der kroate duvnjak
aber auch der trotzte werder bremen
rutscht immer tiefer in den
abstiegsstrudel der fußball bundesliga 0
2 gegen hoffenheim bedeutete weiter
tabellenplatz 16 hoffenheim ist nun
siebter
francesco friedrich dominiert erneut das
geschehen im bob weltcup nach dem sieg
im zweier gewinnt er am königssee auch
im vierer vor teamgefährte johannes
lochner sieg für johannes ludwig beim
rodel-weltcup in sigulda lettland bei
schwierigen witterungsbedingungen holt
ludwig den ersten saison erfolg für
deutschlands rennrodler vor dem weltcup
führenden roman rebroff russland und dem
österreicher david gleicher rekord
weltmeister felix loch wird nur 27
zweiter platz für benedikt doll beim
biathlon weltcup in pokljuka slowenien
im massenstart über 15 kilometer trifft
boll 19 von 20 schuss und ist auch auf
der strecke stark erhält dort unter
anderem den weltcupführenden martin
fourcade aus frankreich und den starken
norweger johannes team ist auf distanz
den sieg holte sich der franzose quanta
fiona je ball verteidigt rang zwei im
ziel knapp vor dem norweger will
für die deutschen biathleten ein
erfreulicher abschluss des letzten
weltcups vor der wm
rang vier für stefan bier beim skisprung
weltcup in zakopane polen mit 139 und
134 metern fehlt insgesamt nur knapp ein
meter auf den sieger kamil stoch der
pole gewinnt vor stefan kraft österreich
und seinem landsmann david kubatzki karl
geiger verteidigt als fünfter das gelbe
trikot des weltcupführenden ja und mehr
wintersport ergebnisse unter zdf
sport.de prima ich hab das wetter noch
bonn zeigt sich die sonne nur noch im
südosten von westen her regnet es
zeitweise temperaturen maximal vier bis
elf grad und die kommenden tage werden
nass windig und kühl aus dem regen wird
auch in tieferen lagen schnee so viele
von uns in zehn minuten mehr gibt es von
marietta slomka im heute journal um
21.45 danke für ihr interesse morgen
freut sich petra gerster hier auf sie
und jetzt theo koll machen sie sich
einen angenehmen abend rund eur theo